this was the first time Shakir ad Zada
had been on his land in 30 years he
broadcast life to his family as he
entered his home in
fizi it was in territory recaptured from
Armenian control by aani
forces but these moments were his
last his daughter struggles with birds
as she recalls that day
shakers scar hit an anti-tank mine near
his home and killed him and his daughter
brother and another
relative at first we were told that they
were just injured but a few hours later
we knew all of them were dead they just
wanted to rebuild their unfinished lives
the Armenians laid Minds not only in
homes but under trees and even
cemeteries
every few weeks controlled explosions to
get rid of Mines can be heard in areas
which were under Armenian
control the Dem mining operation is
dangerous and these pictures were taken
using a
drone rockets and anti-tank mines can be
clearly seen at the former line of
contact between the two
[Music]
armies azan's territory is contaminated
with different types of mins and unex
exploded
Munitions search and clearance
operations are underway in fields
cemeteries Orchards and residential
areas the information that Armenian
sites shared with us only covers uh the
uh areas of the former line of contact
however More than 70% of the uh incident
mine incidents that happen with uh local
population mining was done
indiscriminately uh there is lack of
information in the last three decades at
least 3 and a half thousand people
including hundreds of children have been
killed by mines the anti-mine agency
estimates 1 and a half million mines
have been left behind by The Armenian
military and Dem mining operations like
this are going to require time and
resources it's a painstaking process the
recommended safe distance while this
machine works is 250 M the UN says mine
can be made for less than a dollar but
it takes more than $1,000 to safely
remove
it it will take years before roads in
kabak are fully open and farmers can
tell their fields if that happens at all
and for many here like G it's all too
late and she can only remember her
father's presence through the trees he
planted
sjer H's Village kabak
region make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz